hey uh we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192 david p
the mask drama will not end yesterday
the eggman called in
about masks now we have another caller
calling in about what the eggman said
about masks let's take a listen to it
together
and this is regarding masks and what the
egg man
said he's pretty much right people
shouldn't be wearing masks outside they
probably
didn't have to but in terms of
businesses
it's up to the business yeah and guess
what in terms of public transportation
i don't know if the egg man takes the
subway or buses
no the egg man lives very rurally he's
not on any subway
but guess what we're expecting like the
worst flu season in
years all right the only reason it was
down
was because people were married wearing
masks that's true
fall on winter and it's there's
there's going to be more and more
variants that maybe the
flu vaccines can't keep up with so
i'm still going to be wearing a mask on
the subways and bosses
yeah i i feel like for the most part
everybody's on the same page
what the eggman said is true cdc says if
you're vaccinated you really don't need
to wear it anywhere
what this guy says is true which is we
could be up for a bad flu season
flu season was light last year because
of all the mask wearing what this guy
says is true about
um businesses can ask people to wear
masks
uh and it may make sense to put masks
back on as we get close to flu season or
on public transit and what the egg man's
daughter said about
i don't want people to look at me and
give me dirty looks because i'm not all
of these things are true
and i think we've got to get beyond this
from a medical perspective if you're
vaccinated
it seems you don't really have to wear a
mask anywhere but anyone might choose to
for whatever reason is relevant to them
that's the
it doesn't matter why someone chooses to
wear a mask it may be because they
misunderstand the science
it may be because they want to hide
their face it may be for whatever other
reason
and i think that that's all fine we
don't all have to get bent out of shape
about this
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we are going to preview the biden
putin meeting which we will then cover
the press conference about
uh live later this week we will talk
about
uh israel banning the sale of almost all
fur clothing just flat out and the
implications
we will also talk about the average age
of vehicles has hit an
all-time high and cars trucks and suvs
are getting older on average as used car
prices have been going up this started
during the pandemic and it is continuing
all of that and more and i will be
joined by producer pat
on today's award-winning bonus show
exclusively awards we've invented
but we've won all of them and i think
for a lot of people that makes a big
difference
sign up at joinpacman.com a coupon code
available a better 21 i will see you
then or otherwise tomorrow
for the longest time i was having
trouble finding snacks
that are healthy but actually taste
great and fill me up and satisfy a
craving
and that's why it's great that i
stumbled upon monk pack
and we asked them to be one of our
sponsors monk pack
keto nut and seed bars our delicious
snacks that have one gram of sugar or
less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a keto or
low carb diet
or anybody who like me just prefers to
eat a low sugar diet
i love the monk pack keto nut and seed
bars
because it's really just a great balance
of sweet and salty soft and chewy
but with a nice crunch from the nuts and
seeds flavors include
caramel or caramel you tell me sea salt
sea salt dark chocolate and peanut
butter dark chocolate that's my favorite
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code
pacman